what does this mean to you and like what
is your reaction to all of this i mean
it's so crazy like my i just think of my
first trip coming to los angeles being
in hollywood to work on my first album
i was 16
and i visited the uh hollywood boulevard
came to the walk of fame i took out this
photograph my first trip i was in this
hoodie this was my i dropped i left high
school i had my i had my hoodie with me
i still have it this was my favorite
hoodie in high school skateboarding is
not a crime i never imagined in a
million years 20 years later
that i would have a star on the
hollywood walk of fame i am so grateful
and i'm from a really small town in
canada so like
you know it's still like pinch me i
can't believe it happened i just love
music and i love songwriting and it's
just been such a
beautiful experience been
the 20 years has flown by but
also like kind of not but um just yeah
so grateful for the fan base for this
star and to just i can't wait for the
next 20 years of my career to see to see
where i have so much inspiration and
drive i love music more than ever i'm
songwriting like crazy and i have tons
of fun projects working on a skater boy
film
and i can't i can't wait for the next
20. and then lastly shout out to the
fans in canada i saw somebody with a
sign today do you have any message
sorted for them oh my god i mean i'm
from canada and that's you know it all
started there and i'm saying on stage
with shania twain when i was 14 and
um i have so much love for canada and
i'm just
so thankful and my family is all back
home they're not here today but i love
you my family in canada